hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts actionable insights delivered
through the seamless workflow of the
Jean reader NGS system presented by John
Lehman I am Brenda Kelly Kim elaborates
and I will be your moderator for today's
presentation today's educational web
seminars presented by laberd's the
leading scientific social networking
site and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning we'd also
like to acknowledge the C and E M media
group for helping with programming a
promotion of the event this webinar is
sponsored by kaijin molecular
diagnostics hygiene molecular
diagnostics provides solutions from
sample to result the companion
diagnostic testing oncology infectious
disease and detection of sexually
transmitted diseases and latent
tuberculosis see more at WWE
us products molecular diagnostics before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of a presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of our presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in a slide window to
enlarge this window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button lower left to let us know you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
to obtain your credits I'd now like to
introduce today's presenter John Lehman
John Lehman is the senior director and
global development lead for NGS at
kyochon he has published 25 papers sits
on several scientific advisory boards
and is an inventor on numerous issued
patents patent
applications for more information on
John please click on his photo image at
the top right please join me today
welcoming John Lehman I will now turn it
over to him for his presentation
I missed the introduction but I'm sure
so thank you everybody
appreciate everyone's time and today I'd
like to walk you through hyejin's
offering for a sample to insight
workflow I'd like to spend some time to
take you not only through the basis of
what forms are sampled inside work
though and how we arrived at the content
which of course is the most critical
part but I'm also then walk you through
the workflow itself and give you some
some clarity into what that process
entails and why we think that's going to
be of interest to a wide number of users
so obviously I think everybody's pretty
much the opinion that that NGS solutions
are rapidly becoming more and more
constant within the research community
and certainly with that as it moves from
the very basic research and a venue to
to more of an applied field there are a
couple of challenges that have to be
handled and have to be addressed before
that can adoption so let's just break
those down into four rough categories
here one of those of course is is if
we're going to discuss the use of
targeted panels the actual question of
designing the panel itself and so their
questions are for example which genes
should be included and why which
variances you never get why and
typically at least in my experience this
may come down to kind of a hit list of
genes that are of particular interest
within a particular lab driven by
perhaps the interests of the PIR
postdocs or
our leaders and then this is going to be
kind of a constantly moving target
because these are based rather than any
solid kind of actionable data but but
more driven by the literature which is
my little balls so that's that's a
moving target and that creates issues
secondly there's always the questions of
the interpretation itself
NGS generates a large amount of data
it's one of the attractive features of
it obviously but how do you handle that
large amount of data not only from up
from the interpretation side but really
from some of the data itself where do
you store it how do you store it what
what you do with all that data but then
from some of the interpretation aspect
how do you go from this raw data to
meaningful and and and eventually actual
results there's a question of ports of
information overload there is a lot of
data that we generate what do you do
with numbers of these variants of
uncertain significance that come through
what might a clinical researcher do
those what actions do you take based on
findings that maybe are less than
certain but could potentially have
real-world impact and then lastly
there's there's you know certainly cost
issues all of that data that you
generate can lead to unnecessary work
whether that's the bioinformatics
analysis and the interpretation
questions all of these issues storage
are all resulting in higher costs extra
work and then we also have remember that
them's unnecessary testing is in fact
costly to laboratories is going to be
undermining various business cases that
may be set up around that so these are
kind of four basic adoption challenges
that so to address those and to
certainly ease the transition of NGS
from a strictly research tool it's more
applied hygiene offers two big big
improvements on one it's the use of
actionable insights where the reports
that kind of generates using our gene
panels are proven and relate directly to
to
various ones you can actually do
something about and secondly this would
be the second part of the talk we'll
discuss a little bit about that the
workflow how we have the first truly
complete workflow for the NGS system
where you have one partner who provides
an entire solution not only from
purified DNA but really as we'll show
from FFPE all the way through to the
report so that actionable insights where
we're creating the actionable reports
the interesting thing about this job
which I find particularly unique is that
the whole basis of the gene panel that
we use for these acts of insights it
stems from the Qaeda knowledge base and
the knowledge base is a database that
kaijin has generated it's it's
comprehensive its industry-leading
really and as you can see here it's it's
a compilation of multiple different
sources both public and proprietary and
it's it's really this this has to be
can't be stressed heavily enough
it's expertly curated and continuously
upgraded or updated to provide this kind
of up-to-date knowledge and so as you
can see you can form that the knowledge
base takes the the information from drug
labels from clinical trials
from external databases professional
guidelines and then then lastly you have
scientific literature the clinical case
counts and those run through
specifically to that kind of expert
Jason so that's the basic kinda
knowledge base now how we use that to
guide the panel design is kind of unique
because traditionally I think people
take their their list of favorite genes
or listed favorite variants and you
generate a panel with these and then you
go and try to determine what what
actions can you take what do those with
those variants mean we took the reverse
we essentially two stood the the
conventional wisdom on its head and
instead of starting kind of thumb from
the
and trying to see which which disease
types who could apply it to instead we
took the tumor type to the five top
tumor types in this case and we then
took went to the to the knowledge base
itself and look for variants that were
linked and medical acts ability within
those specific tumor types and so as a
result we figured that we determined
which which amplicons
and then from those amplicons which was
a panel that result in their necessary
and sufficient list of variants that
would give maximal actionability in
clinical research for those top tumor
types so in this case what we were doing
is we took the tumor types the five
tumor types and instead of using and
this is kind of important if we didn't
use the entire knowledge base to inform
this decision instead we stuck with a
rather conservative approach of only
using data that came from drug labels
clinical trials informational guidelines
okay we did not rely on the scientific
literature because that is more of an
academic kind of pure research element
extremely important for some people
absolutely but in this case we were
looking for more conservative
conservative guidance and we didn't use
the external databases so well what we
did so again I said that it was top five
tumor types and so in this case we use
breast ovarian and colorectal and well
we chose these five on the basis of the
prevalence the health impact and
critically the the availability of
targeted therapies and so what came out
what you know I'm gonna jump back really
quickly so you see kind of going into
the query itself would be these five
tumor types they can win in the lodge
base and then the result which comes out
if these twelve genes which are listed
below Krsna asked it the RAF pdgfra al
EGFR Kerby to pik3ca herb III yes are so
those are the genes that came out as
having the highest percentage of
actionable insights of actionable
variants that would be linked to
targeted therapies
so we're going to just take a quick walk
through the panel the panel those those
those 12 genes
obviously we're covered by a specific
panel so I'll take a quick walk through
the panel itself and give you some
insights into that so the panel sides
itself and then we will actually just
isn't just kind of sharing detail for
details sake who then compare it to some
of the existing panels that are on the
market and so panel size itself we said
it's 12 genes only covered 16.7
kilobases of data but from that and this
is important there are 773 unique
variant positions though it's variant
positions are covered by three hundred
and thirty amp cons okay so and if we
take a look at this we'll see that the
they give us a variant frequency where
industry feels comfortable calling which
is five percent we can actually go more
we've got obviously and what's really
interesting about this is the 330
amplifies and you'll see that the
variant positions is office obviously
multiple variants additions within
specific amplicons
but when we look at the coverage and
this is using just kind of a test case
using any 128 78 DNA but twelve
different data sets you'll see that oh
closed amplicons needs the entire
amplifies we get 98.5 percent of those
amplicons to have a coverage of greater
than 200 X and 96.4% those amplicons
have greater than coverage of 500
minutes so that's the amplicon for again
what I mentioned was that were
specifically interested in the insight
in the variant themselves and so these
applicants are designed to maximize
coverage of specific variants and so
when we look at that the numbers are
even more impressive we're looking at
99.9 percent of the variants are covered
a greater than - the other day and 99.8%
are greater than 500 X so I think that
that should be an indication this is a
well-designed panel it covers the target
variants extremely well
it comes in with a very low number of
amplicons and let's see how that looks
in comparison to what are the other
tuned kind of major oncology related
panels that are out there so again this
is just a distillation of our first of
the gene reader AIT panel actionable
insights team battle in leftmost column
and then we compare that to the Illumina
in the center and amp let's see thermo
fisher ampliseq panel on the far right
side i won't see that of the of the
panels that are there the gene reader
panel is the smallest not only in terms
of genes that are covered but also in
sheer amount of data that's provided our
genetic information that's covered fewer
variants are covered here we all 773
concentrating again on these unique
variant positions the number isn't
listed for the aluminum panel but it's
2800 almost 3,000 variants for the FOC
however interestingly you'll notice that
again we covered the smaller amount in
why the largest number of amplicons and
so that's that's sneaking in expect and
all these have the same basic level of
variant frequency that they they
prescribed to the 5% cut off or above
however when we look at the coverage
again show the embassy coverage here or
excuse me the actual insight tumor panel
here and compare that to the other ones
you see the 98.5 percent greater than
200 X average coverage of 5000 X for the
level as opposed to 93.5% for the panel
and the numbers aren't actually given
for the for the coverage for the embassy
however we get greater than 500 or 5000
X coverage for the AIT panel on a
parabola con basis whereas you get
somewhere between a thousand to four
thousand for the embassy so what we're
really seeing is that although the
coverage the number of genes is higher
in the Illumina and the amplitude panel
the level of coverage as you might
expect is lower and then we look at the
variable insights which which because
they are the other two competitors are
inside related
but let's take a look at the actual
genes of the are covered so there are
twelve genes that ant will see covers
let's take a look at these and see what
the level of coverage is with Indians so
this is just a general Venn diagram and
so in the very center of the Venn
diagram the take a step back
the blue circle are those that the genes
that are in the hygiene action sites and
the black is the thermal amplitude panel
hotspot you'll see that there are eight
overlapping genes that are covered in
all that are common to all three of
those panels that Fisher forty two genes
covered in we've got 17 genes that are
in the tumor offering and then
interestingly even though it's a low
number of genes the smallest number of
genes overall there are four teams that
are unique to the so let's take a look
at the at the genes so even on those
eight genes that are covered and they're
listed on the Left let's take a look at
those genes that are covered in all of
them
so we've already acknowledged that there
are some genes that are covered in one
panel not the other but let's take a
look at the insights kind of these
actionable variants that you can find in
the genes that are covered and so if we
take a look at this you just this is the
in comparison to the coverage the
variants covered in the actionable
insight this is just a listing by gene
of a number of actionable insights that
are not covered in either the two so for
example from within GFR there are 58
insights of very variants that aren't
covered by thermo Fisher 28 and then
there are actually 21 of those that
aren't covered by either panel that are
found in the in the actual and so we can
run through all the different genes and
what at the end of the day for these
eight that are in common you find that
there are eighty-one variants that
aren't covered in either of those two
paddles that are found so again this
just speaks to I think two things one is
the
the design criteria that was used on
again using the medical information the
clinical research information the
existing data that's out there to guide
which variants we thought we should be
investigating and designing panel
specifically to cover those but also the
ability that we were able to really
specifically target those variants so
now this is going a little deeper so in
this case what we're going to do is
we're going to take a look at example of
one of these variants that was found
only in the kind of elderly I mean I
think the question obviously is raised
okay so there are variants and recovered
the hyejung coverage that other
companies don't but are those important
variants you know what's just dig into
one particular case there are many
others but in this case what we're going
to look at is we're going to look at it
variant that's common or be tuned and
you know here it is outlined in the red
box and you can see that it's a missense
mutation so the first thing we find is
that actually the question of whether
it's relevant at all it certainly it
pops up in 27 different publications so
this is at the very basic kind of
research level this is in fact of
relevant mutation as it's been covered
fairly extensively in different
mutations so from that sign alone
perhaps but if we actually begin to take
a look at those publications what are
they covering these just strictly
research interest or these have some
some applied sensibilities certainly we
look into those nature that's frontiers
oncology and we kind of this mutation is
activating mutation and it's actually so
again this seems to be increasingly
relevant and if you research a little
more significant frequencies and as I
said it's
so then actually if we could begin
further we find that some of the
patient's are indicating that it's
actually associated with drug the spot
so again one would make the claim that
this is and now look at so we've
established the fact that that this and
now look at the back end of the system
again there's a little bit more when we
talk about the workflow but the TCI the
ingenuity backbone of the the violent
romantic software is what really
provides that linkage that connects the
researcher from the data that they've
generated using actual insights tumor
panel to the the data this kind of
actionability the relevance of what
they're finding so if we this would be
this is an indication of the report that
would that would be generated on the
basis of identifying this particular
variant first of all what you get is is
obviously the classification finger con
can kind of the diagnosis that might
come up this is just a demo view but
that might come up secondly it would
identify and flash to the to the
researcher that this is a somatic
mutation and I'm not seen in the general
population and you would get the allelic
frequency would be calculated and the
the cause though or the impact of that
but it's a gain of function mutation but
also be noted but it goes actually the
QC I again goes one step further and not
only does it does it give you the
information that I've showed on this
line identifying a pathogenic nature
that variant but then there we go
also it identifies potential associated
therapy options and and associated
clinical trials that might be available
so for example here we see that it gives
links to to the guidelines and also
lights up very
detail you can see this but it defies
what phase clinical trials are where the
locations of this clinical trials are so
again providing providing a lot level of
detail that isn't found wouldn't be
available to your standard researcher
guidelines there we go treatment
capabilities and so forth so that's
that's where that panel come not only
the front end of what the panel design
stem strong but also what the enables a
greater utilization generated so now
we're going to take a little bit of walk
through in the last bit of the slide
we're going to take a walk through
through or the the presentation we'll
walk through the workflow and then we'll
last go through some of the data that
was generated so as I said the panel
that we showed was just in a part of
that complete NGS solution so if we
really look at the NGS solution the NGS
workflow itself a million starts with
nucleic acid extraction you're gonna go
to a target enrichment a library
preparation
amplification the sequencing itself
which a lot of people pay perhaps too
much attention to we have to remember
it's just kind of one part of an entire
workflow and then finally the data
analysis interpretation so you know
they're obviously QC steps that are
built into this variant confirmation and
and again as opposed to some workflows
on the workloads that have traditionally
been released and are available on the
market where there is no complete
solution those situations require the
individual researcher to assemble
various bits and components and some
from one manufacturer some from another
so may even be kind of home rolled
bioinformatics open-source solutions and
those obviously some
but again so as I said we've got that
we've got this this work complete
workflow so again we've got the kite
queue which is which is proven effective
for your clinic acid extraction FFP for
example we also then have the target of
Richmond which occurs on our agility the
preparation of libraries of taking your
amplicons and converting them into the
material which would be used in
subsequent sequencing which then goes
into next generation sequencing
application stages preparation and the
application is automated also on and
amplified material is sequence of the
gene reader data analysis occurs with
GCI analyzed and then the interpretation
is you mentioned it for the last part of
the actual inside section it's gonna
interpret however I think we all have to
recognize that there are these these QC
steps able to provide solutions to those
as well so the key step that's been
extracted from the FFPE how much do you
have and what quality is it that can be
done online system we don't have
targeted enrichment where we go through
the IXL will ensure that the material is
of the proper concentration proper
quality and then a similar step can be
done on the library except for Nathan
generated before they go into the motion
PCR and amplification which is done also
on the guy cells so we cover all of
those upstream QC steps and imports
there's support and not only are we
providing the system itself and the QC
steps but there's a level of support
that we're able to provide and there's a
couple of really intriguing features
that can one that is extremely useful
once the gene eight assistant where the
entire workflow in various hints and
kind of foot starts are included on
and then of course there's the greater
question which is how do you handle the
data right and this is where we've seen
in the past where alerts quite common
for people to rely on their lineage
system perhaps or a simple bunch of data
management software's but here we
provide a gene read link which has the
true kind of sampled insight coverage of
so there I mean I think I just I won't
jump back you'll have to go through that
whole animation all over again
one point that I did want to hit was it
you know we're able to provide not only
the it's significant enough I think that
guide provides the entire workflow but
we really went the extra mile to make
sure that not only are we providing the
quality control steps and the guidance
based on those but the obviously the
support and then on top of that you've
got access to the the hygiene technical
support and customer support teams
because all every step of the process is
a kind of process are able to provide
expert support and guidance but this is
just now I'm going to kind of talk about
some of the challenges in the workflow
itself and in some of the other areas
that they're kinda you can really bring
a solution to this so for example FFPE
I think the challenges variable fixed or
the fixation the type of filtration all
these things are such that you're doing
a large study the challenge of
four-month artifacts
see different versions that come as a
result of fixation and the fact that
frankly it's a manual process lots of
manual steps and so by taking this this
process and automating it it's the very
first step we're able to provide
maximize yield and quality for those
those FFPE steps through this is kind of
known people use this it's a know
inspected FFPE samples process we also
include enzymatic steps to correct armed
facts that are generated and the manual
process itself as I said it's no longer
manual its automated on the kite cube
which is going to give you a much higher
level of reproducibility consistency and
in frankly as I said the gene reader
again is talk about the sequencer too so
much then it's simply part of a
connected workflow
you know there's as I said before
there's this kind of challenge when we
look at the standard workflows that are
an ad hoc collection of multiple
different vendors and instruments one is
that lack of a connected upstream
workflow that lack of application
flexibility you may have developed and
workflow for yourself that really is the
only access to particular applications
and of course and so we're able to
address these things again the kind of
solution really starts with it's truly
integrated it starts with that FFPE
processing itself so really starts at
the core of the solution
the surprising amount of flexibility as
far as the gene reader itself we're able
to process anywhere from ten to four
samples and those can either be
simultaneously so you can either if you
have four examples you can put them all
on the floor flow cells and run them at
the same time or as we know many lab
situations the sample float
to be process and so you can start if
you have ten ten samples that come in
you can start a flow so of those then
later 20 flow cells to man you can start
the next two flow so and then you can
wait and 10 more come in any combination
that you like so it really gives that
level of flexibility that I think small
Labs is really going to find very
compelling when they don't have that
solid base of data the lack of content
talking about that again we have been
designed from the ground up and we
talked about the downstream violent
chromatic solution not only is that
seamless so there's no interpretations
built right into it so we think this is
a real kind of compelling workflow there
we want to begin a little more on the
bioinformatics solution which certainly
would be with the acquisition of CLC and
their ingenuity pipelines I think this
is something that maybe doesn't give we
take it for granted and don't give it
enough but attention when we look at
bioinformatics itself certainly in labs
I visit past that's been something that
simply training people has been a real
challenge but here kind of that whole
time consuming data analysis can be
disconnected from some of the work that
generates it where data analysis I'd
wanted to kind of generalize for for
alternatives other than specific to the
at hand and you really require these
kind of super trained gurus to use these
complex tools and again the the
interpretation can be can be a challenge
and as we discussed the ingenuity
solution really has a way of turning
this time-consuming process into a
seamless solution
the its pre-designed the the entire
analysis pre-designed to conduct the
data analysis specific to that that
panel and the the regardless of the
level of we've also taken the level of
expertise required not only for the
analysis but for the interpretation
obviously we're now the ingenuity is
able to give that data in a
interpretable level to research and
regardless of their level of expertise
so you know I think that both on on the
on the typical wet bench area where I
think a lot of the attention gets paid
but also to the extremely important so
now what we're gonna do is take a detour
into some of the data this is the result
of a study that we did in conjunction
with the road and what we were looking
to do here was can use the action blend
sites tumor panel on a rasp sample and
what we were were interested in doing
was generating correlation between so
just the study itself we were using the
junior year NGS systems typical kind of
QC analyze and interpret as the back end
the samples themselves were 43 different
role of rectal samples the FFPE and they
aged and years in age from anywhere from
three to twenty years and so to say that
that some of this data was highly
fragmented I think would be an
understatement some of it was really
pretty beaten up now when showing some
data previously we were using any 128 so
the ASD now here we're using the FFPE
samples so this stuff is really as I
said extremely beaten up
and what we see is that there is you do
see a dip
and we can see that this this suffers a
bit when you're looking when you've
moved from these purified genomic DNA
and down the FFPE you get 97 percent
greater than 200 X and 92 percent of
greater than 500 that's what well look
at the insights and this is what we
really care about is the coverage on the
inside and as they said these panels are
specifically designed to achieve maximal
coverage even a different sample
difficult samples like he's fragmented
ever getting 99.8% of the of the variant
bases covered and created into a hundred
X XI and greater than 90 our 98.6% of
the bases are greater than covered at
500 X so these these were really to do
so you get lots of lots of amplified
coverage lots of over coverage to make
sure that now here's kind of the
interesting thing here is that what
we're interested in doing was looking at
the Thera screen assay which which
covers these same mutations and some
parts you can see acid and the third
screen is and we wanted to see how well
the gene reader compared to those so
what we're looking at using a 5 percent
vary and and based on previous Thera
screen and pyrosequencing assays we were
able to determine that 14 of these
samples were mutation and 29 of the
samples and when we ran those same
samples the same samples but different
ffe slices through the gene reader
system we were able to get 100%
concordance and so I think this is this
is the first time to my knowledge that
we've shown concordance between an NGO
system the ther screen but also with the
fire sequence a so two different
orthogonal assays are giving 100
according to the NGS system in a
real-world situation and challenging
sample types in this case so we were
extremely encouraged to see this result
so we if we dig into this a little
further and we decided to add to the to
the pool comparison with a my seat so
this was done again in conjunction with
a throw that rode at the samples and did
all the generator work and the my seek
work itself so if we take a look at the
14 of these these samples the 14 and the
specific mutations that they have what
you'll see is that in the left-hand
column you see the Theron screening
assay or the pyro sequencing assay and
in the case in when there's a number
that's the frequency of the allele in
which case that you have indicates the
Huayra sequencing was used to generate
the data however because their screen is
just a digital PCR based assay you need
to get an absence or a mine there are an
absence sort of presence of the bearing
so in that case we'll just have a plus
in that column but you don't have any
and what you see is that the above 5
percent frequency we also get a hundred
percent concordance between the gene
reader and the my seat and the my seek
and the pharisee acid so again this is
just these assays are all kind of
arriving at the same and so for us again
just further confirmation of the action
so I spent a little time earlier talking
about how we were able to do using the
hydrogen offering of the FFPE kit how
that's really designed to use FFPE for
the front end and how that's able to
address the formal and fixation
artifacts and so this is a study where
we went in and really investigated what
is the impact of using this specific and
one thing I want to be perfectly clear
where you're gonna just before we get
into the data it just so this is first
and foremost in people's mind what we
did was we went and we generated samples
both using
the gene reader DNA FFT kit which has
the error correction and all of the all
the kind of benefits of the kind of get
then we use the standard sample
preparation now these samples were run
on both the my seek and the jr. this is
not a comparison of the my seek and the
gene reader one to the other
this is rather a comparison of two
different FS the sample preparation
processes which were one on both
sequencing systems simply because we
didn't want to find that fit perhaps we
were chasing an artifact that was
related to a specific sequencing system
so I just want to be clear about that so
people don't take the wrong message out
of this out of this particular slide so
if we look at this data you'll see that
with its standard and we're gonna be
looking at two different things one it's
the on the left hand column we look at
the standard sample preparation versus
the gene read atrophy and then we'll
look at the variants that are identified
on the various platforms and either 5%
cut off at 2.5% cut off or a greater
than 1% cut off okay so we're gonna kind
of lower the sensitivity in three
separate increments as we move forward
so if we look at just the five basic 5%
variant you'll see that with the
standard sample graph we get 1516
variants identified with a standard
sample Pro versus 14 variants that are
identified with the gene read so well
they're fairly equivalent it's really
hard to say that there's anything
anything particular going on there
however if you drop down to and broaden
that window and say we're moving
interested in variants that are greater
than 2.5% something very interesting
happens so regardless of the sequencing
platform you use be at my seat via teen
rear you see that suddenly when you go
in 2.5% the number of mutations that you
detect goes up to 25 from almost almost
you're looking at 25 with the standard
you know 25 regardless of the platform
of the standard sample preparation
however when you do that same analysis
using the number doesn't change you
still have 14 variants so relaxing that
window decreasing that
sensitivity cutoff you still haven't
identified any additional variants and
so certainly the concern is that we're
looking at these these formal and
fixation variants that we're beginning
to now to see we need to call them as
real variants and it gets the problem
gets significantly worse if we go down
to 1% now it's not reported for the my
seat and that has nothing to do with my
seat DNA is everything to do with just
the analysis software that was used it
doesn't go down that one so that's an
issue with the data and also software
what if we compare the gene reader using
the standard sample craft versus
generator using the DNA kit you'll see
that you get 38 detected variants at one
percent or greater the artifact
correction inherent in the DNA so
regardless of whether you're looking at
at five percent or 2.5 percent you get
no more additional variants detective
and and only a single artefactual berry
so a really compelling story for we feel
for for the value of using the so a
quick summary here I hope I've presented
a compelling case that the hydrogen is
in generating that sample to incite work
though that first real comprehensive
offering we're able to offer not only
the actionable insights that the data is
generated with an eye towards specifying
that panel ensuring accurate coverage
high quality data and and truly relevant
output through not only the gene mail
but you seamless bioinformatics but also
we're able to provide that that complete
workflow where you get a single partner
he's able to provide everything from an
optimized front end
under under manufacturer so you know
that if all the parts of it designed in
concert with each other you don't get an
upgrade in one system that hasn't been
fully tested with the entire workflow so
you get ease-of-use for the entire
process you get that efficiency from
from insight and you also had the peace
of mind knowing that the expertise at
triage in a company that's known for
service and thank you John for that
informative presentation it is time for
our Q&A if I add audience has a question
you'd like to ask John you can do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left type your question into
the box that appears on the screen and
hit Send we'll try to answer as many of
your questions as we have time for now
our first question we have for John what
are the main advantages of the gene
reader system
other companies currently do
great thanks for that answer we do have
another question from an attendee what
future panels or content do you have
planned for the gene reader another good
question I think that'd be a question I
would I would definitely head towards
our good to know thank you
we do have another question an attendee
asks do I need a bioinformatic Titian to
run or manage the qci software you know
I can only answer from our experience
here in a lab where certainly I'm
capable of running the software I'm not
so I think it's certainly designed not
to require that you know I think a lot
of labs do I think that that but we
obviously don't use by train by open
positions but it's not required
okay we have another question can you
please explain more how the four flow
cells work sure happy dude so the I
guess I provide the level of detail that
I hope is informative and please feel
free to follow up in the other question
if I don't if I don't address the main
concerns so the the gene reader is built
with a turntable kind of imagine year
old for those of you old enough to
remember records turntable at the heart
of the system which enables anywhere
from one to four flow cells to be placed
on the system for sequencing and the
system is designed such that if you put
four flow cells on at once the rawness
included in the same amount of time that
it takes there's no additional time
required for them for the flow cells for
flow cells however what you can do is is
the unique feature about this is that
you are able to start the run with a
single flow cell and it can proceed you
know however long as the user lights and
then you can actually add anywhere up to
the total number of four flow cells at
that time kind of out of in a staggered
fashion so it really allows the users to
load the system load the samples such as
they have them rather than waiting for
enough samples to have for example to
fill all four cells so that's I hope
that answers the question I don't know
if there's additional level of detail
required I'd be happy to happy to answer
itself
thank you John we're getting close on
time we have time for one more question
our question is what is the total
turnaround time for analysis from sample
to report questions so again and just to
frame the question to frame the question
here we're talking about from an FFPE
slice all the way out to the report
generation and that the entire process
itself is is including the seamless
bioinformatics including the sample
preparation library preparation
enrichment takes five days the
sequencing aspect actually for someone
who's kind of been dealing with
sequencing as long as I have it's a
little unusual that's that's not the
greatest part I mean it's it's it's
certainly a component but you know the
entire process takes takes five days
right it's great fast turnaround time we
have no more time for questions I do
want to turn it right back again to John
layman for any final comments or advice
you might have for our attendees no
advice I guess thanks everybody for
their attention thank you for the
questions if you have further follow-up
questions I'm assuming that there are
ways for you to contact sales marketing
team that takes a fourteen-year at agent
and if there are technical questions
obviously I'd be more than happy to have
them forward on to me and I will address
them as best I can but again just thanks
everybody for their attention
thank you John lots of good information
today I would also like to thank our
sponsor cryogen malt molecular
diagnostics for making this presentation
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through the end of August 2016 attendees
will receive an email from lab roots
letting them know when this webcast is
available from replay and we would
invite you to share that announcements
with your colleagues who might have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thank you again for joining us and
we hope you see you another time goodbye